Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here, and
today I want to talk about ChatGPT
again, in a little more detail.
I've done a bit of research.
Uh, I looked up, uh, you know, what
some people are saying about how
to use it for different purposes,
including language learning.
Uh, I may forget some of these things
as I go through this, but what I
thought I would do is actually have
you share my screen as I go to ChatGPT
and attempt to  have it perform
different tasks or activities for me.
Remember that when it comes to
language learning, uh, everything
comes down to your attitude.
That is the attitude of the learner,
the amount of time you spend, and of
course, how efficiently that time is
spent spent with the language, and
then things that you're able to notice
in the language and your ability to
notice, as I've said before, increases
if you have a positive attitude.
If you want to notice, and with more
time spent with the language, you
inevitably notice more and more things.
So if ChatGPT  is going to help us,
it's gotta make us more motivated,
it's gonna make our, you know,
use of time more efficient is
gonna help us to notice things.
That's the way I see it.
So essentially in, in whether learning
languages or using languages uh, and
for both the sort of activities that are
available to us are reading, listening,
speaking, writing, and then dealing
with issues of grammar or correct usage.
So how does chat or how can ChatGPT
be used in these various areas?
Remember, ChatGPT is text-based, so it, I
don't understand all the technology, but
it, it, it search sort of searches, all
kinds of texts that has been produced over
however much time in various languages
and is able to generate answers to
whatever it is you, you ask it to do.
So it has no audio.
However, if you want to use audio,
you have to then use another
form of, uh, you know, artificial
intelligence, convert the audio to text.
If you want to listen to what
ChatGPT generates, again, you have
to use another form of artificial
intelligence, which is text to speech.
But we'll get back to that.
We'll get to that later on.
So we are now in ChatGPT  hopefully,
and I could say to ChatGPT let's
start out now with reading.
So I could say, uh, you know,
write a story in Italian
about traveling in, uh, Italy.
Okay.
See what the, see what it does with that.
So, as you can see very
quickly, it produces a story.
Now, I don't know how
much it's gonna give us.
We'll see.
Uh, but it has a lot of good
stuff, Maria, blah, blah, blah.
Okay.
So once I have the story, I can now
import this story into LingQ and, uh,
I'll just show you how that works.
Um, yeah.
So I'll go to my Persian.
I'll change the language to Italian.
So now this is material that
I can use to learn, right?
So I go there to import, import a lesson,
and uh, I could call this, uh, whatever
travel, and I have to pick a course.
So, Um, for the, I'll just
call us quick imports.
It doesn't matter.
And so that's gonna be there.
And then here I just copy and paste.
I have to go back into there
and I have to copy the story.
Copy and come back here.
Input the text.
The text is required.
I know that.
Bingo.
And now I basically...
where I forget, oh yeah,
save and generate lesson.
So everything is okay.
I have no audio file to add.
If I had someone record it, I could add
the audio file, save, and generate lesson.
So I have now created a lesson
about traveling in Italy.
Um, let's wait till it's, all right.
New lesson.
Now if I wanted to, I could generate
the lesson audio, so generate lesson
audio because there is no audio.
But I think a lot of people don't like
to listen to stuff in text-to-speech.
...
Okay, so you have a story now that you
can listen to, uh, and study and save
words and phrases and so forth, and.
Let's go back here.
So now we might say, uh,
you know, please, sorry...
so that's content.
By the way.
I, I won't go through all of this,
but, uh, one thing that I did try
doing, I went to, um, uh, Hamlet by
Shakespeare and, uh, grabbed a piece
of text and I asked, um, Maybe there's
a record of it here, maybe not.
I asked, um, ChatGPT to convert it into
modern English, and then I imported
into LingQ and I turned on the text to
speech, so I had audio for it, and I
could listen to parts of Hamlet, uh,
in English, but in modern English,
so you can take any complex or old
text and convert it into modern text.
So a big part of, of, um, I think ChatGPT
is, um, helping you create content.
For example, let's say that you
had to have, you had an interview
coming up in French, uh, a job
with a pharmaceutical company.
Let's do it in English.
Let's say, uh, please write a dialogue,
write a dialogue, uh, between a job
applicant and potential employer for
a um, pharma pharmaceutical company.
Okay.
Let's see what happens here.
Struggling a bit here.
Oh, here we are.
Oh, he's still in Italian.
Very interesting.
So we have a, an interview now in Italian.
I should have specified that this
was in English, but it still thinks
I'm in Italian, but here you go.
You've got a, um, dialogue of a
potential, you know, of an interview
in Italian uh, between someone looking
for a job with a pharmaceutical company
and what the employer might say.
Um, I think you can also have a
dialogue, but I'm not gonna do that.
But you can actually talk to, um, ChatGPT.
I haven't done this.
It's not something that I would do,
but the thing about language learning
and about ChatGPT is that the potential
ways of using it are, are, are, are,
I wouldn't say limitless, but there
are many, many ways you can use it.
So it's gonna be, it's gonna
depend on your needs, on what
you like doing and so forth.
But so obviously ChatGPT is great
for generating written content.
Uh, personally I would be, I would like
to see some way that I could convert
podcast material into accurately
transcribed timestamped transcripts.
But that's not something that
ChatGPT  can do because it has
trouble dealing with audio.
Okay.
So that's reading, speaking.
It doesn't speak, you can't listen
unless you use, uh, text to speech.
Uh, you can write and have
them correct your writing.
So again, I'm not gonna do that, but you
could write something and it will correct.
Um, we won't do that, but you
can imagine how that would work.
And then you would get a
corrected text, which again, you
could import if you wanted to.
But now let's look at sort of what I think
is a real opportunity here is in grammar.
So you say, um, can, let's just...
can you, uh, create a um, summary
of let's go to French and grammar.
Let's see what happens.
I have no idea what they're gonna say.
So you can now get an overview.
That doesn't say much.
Not very useful.
Okay.
Um, please explain in French, how...
sorry, French, how, ah, how to
use French pronouns with examples.
I could be dictating this,
which is another form of...
so we get a lot of useful
stuff if you want to sort of
focus in on French pronouns.
Well, and it could be, you know,
any other aspect of the language.
Uh, and so you'll get something.
And again, I would always ask
for my grammar explanations.
It depends where you are at an
early stage in the language.
You may want your grammar
explanations in English.
Uh, read them, learn them, forget.
And at a later stage, you may want
them in the target language and then
you can import them and use that as
learning material and even attach
an audio file to it if you want.
Okay, so how about please, uh, create.
Uh, 10 sentences in Spanish
featuring the subjunctive.
So now, uh, I'd have to go through
these, um, to make sure they're correct.
I think they are, but I had the
experience when I asked for 10
examples of the instrumental case in
Russian that two of them were wrong.
So, but it doesn't matter.
You can have a few mistakes in wrong
information with enough exposure.
Eventually these things start to click in.
So with providing you with grammar
explanations, uh, I think ChatGPT is good.
The other thing is that it will correct
and it, it'll even tell you what you said.
So, um, if I will go, for example, I don't
got much interest in learning English.
Uh, I thinks it is too tough.
Um, even I learn English,
I ain't gonna get a job.
How about that?
All right.
Oh yeah, please correct
and explain the mistakes...
mistakes.
Wow.
In the following.
So there you have it.
You can correct mistakes
and get some explanations.
So that's just a first attempt at using,
no, we shouldn't say a first attempt
because I've looked at a little bit
before, but in terms of sharing my
experience with you, showing you just
some of the potential that's there.
And I think it's up to every person to
choose, uh, figure out how to use it.
I, I think it's great.
I think it, it gets you some of the
same results as searching in Google.
Obviously you can Google for,
you know, Italian grammar,
French verbs, whatever you want.
Uh, but this is another way of doing it.
It's quite fast.
You can be more specific,
uh, in what you ask for.
And I think as users become more
familiar with the technology, they'll
become better and better at, at
getting from ChatGPT what they want.
So I hope you found that interesting.
I look forward to your comments.
Bye for now.